[Music]
good morning John it's Tuesday July 24th
there hasn't been very much interesting
happening in my life for the last three
days because almost every hour of it has
been taken up either sleeping or reading
Harry Potter I didn't know when the book
was gonna come in the mail the UPS guy
got there like a nine o'clock in the
morning it was pretty vital because it
was important to have as much reading
time as possible that day Kathryn opened
the box and then I took the book out of
the box and then there was a long
silence in which I held the book tightly
and Katherine looked directly into my
eyes I thought it might turn ugly but in
the end we found a solution we decided
to read it together so as to avoid that
particular conflict it may not have been
the most efficient way to read Harry
Potter in fact it took a strangely long
amount of time for a Harry Potter book
but we finished and it was amazing and
it was really kind of nice to be able to
share that with Kathryn the whole
experience of it as sappy as that sounds
I've written the letter dear
nerdfighters who do not care about Harry
Potter I am sorry
I'm going to keep talking about Harry
Potter now you know there's a solution
of the problem of not caring about Harry
Potter read Harry Potter and then you'll
be part of the club and he won't find it
annoying when I talk about Harry Potter
for an entire video again oh my gosh
look it's a canvas sound nerdfighter bag
John when the New York Times contacted
you about you being one of a bunch of
people that they asked a question to
about Harry Potter I think that they
expected a perspective of a young adult
writer so when you pass them my name I'm
not sure what they expected to get but
in any case I am kind of contributing to
the New York Times 200 words on why I
think Harry Potter is so special and
really that's a very good question it
would have been easy for the Harry
Potter books to be just you know another
kid's book fantasy adventure but it is
not just another kid's book fantasy
adventure there's something very
different going on here this is like the
biggest thing that's ever happened in
publishing since like the Bible I very
much enjoyed attempting to answer that
question in the spirit of being a kind
of sort of New York Times contribute
I would like to invite the nerdfighters
into my pants to come and give their
opinion on why they think that Harry
Potter is such a gigantic phenomenon
additionally I would like to suggest
that we make this a tradition Tuesdays
are question days every Tuesday one of
us asks a question of the nerdfighters
like if you were a crayon what color
would you most like to make out with you
guys can go ahead and answer that one -
John I'm sorry that your innards are all
tickly I really wish you had bought that
mountain dew sign it was amazing but I'm
sure you'll be feeling better soon
and I'll see you and hopefully your
green hair tomorrow
you